[Musik]
wir hoffen und schießt ihn ist kommt
wieder
und wenn man die waffen richtig putzt
und mit nova rock die woche zum reinigen
doch das gehäuse über erleichtert dass
wir direkt lösen dann wie so viele
schwarze kind das erste format uhr und
wenn es doch eigentlich schwarz und
sätze auf band oder sind von anderen
duft formal zu erhalten
mit jeder vertritt wieder öfter vom
fluchtort eignet wird man ihm beim
laufen ton und sie hatten in
schussrichtung durch
christ dann haben wir schon mal zum
singer und haben wir leicht probiert bei
marsh dann an rudi seitz umbringe
aber er ist halt haben wir dann
wirklichkeit gibt und also für den
zweiten doping wo das probiert nicht
schlecht
[Musik]
eine absage